could you please pick the odd one out
mm-hmm
it's not difficult right now I mean the
image you see on the screen represents
something a rough idea of what the
British and general filmmaking industry
looks like you see figures revealed by
the Women's Media Center in New York
showed that across a five-year period
ending in the year 2012 of the 500 top
grossing movies only two of those had
black women directors attached to them
that's a naught point four percent and
I'm thinking back now to the night
before I was about to set foot on set of
my first movie ever to direct and I can
tell you now I was absolutely terrified
and my fear pivoted around the fact that
I knew that I wasn't what was expected
of a director I didn't fit the industry
model for stop and I wondered how I was
going to lead my own male crew and they
were also all white how I was going to
instill confidence in them and get them
to believe in me so that I could end up
with the film that I'd written on screen
after all I knew that they had never
worked under anyone that looked like me
before you know my shape my flavor and I
realized essentially that society had
created the very world that I wanted to
work in as one that statistically did
not include me and that society by its
own boundaries and perceptions had
created me to be somebody that didn't
fit into the category of what filmmakers
were generally expected to be and yet I
felt I felt like a director and I knew
that I could craft stories on screen and
those stories to audiences but the
figures they don't lie and the
statistics they did not tally in my
favor
essentially my definition of me didn't
match the definition that society had
bestowed upon me and so who wins and
that's what I want to talk to you about
today the question of who defines you
society or yourself now is society's
opinion of who you are who you can be
what value you have you know what you
can achieve in life is that more
powerful and opinion an important
opinion than your own if you say you're
a writer and you have something valuable
to contribute to the literary world but
you know reviewers and critics they say
you know you're not you're not a great
writer then whose truth wins and whose
truth is most likely to determine your
future as a writer well for me the
answer is really simple it's whichever
you choose to believe and I I have this
idea that since we can all dream a far
bigger dream for ourselves in society
could ever indicate for any of us what
would happen if we all decided that we
were going to actively define our
ourselves and allow that definition to
govern everything over and above
anything that society could define or
indicate for any of us how would that
influence our lives now you know the
question of who defines us comes up in
everybody's life at some point or
another and it doesn't have to be about
race or gender necessarily for me the
question embedded itself long ago I grew
up down the road from here at a time
when Brixton was being so negatively
defined by society
and also defined in a way that it didn't
authentically see itself but it
practically imposed it on itself and it
struggled to be heard and with an older
brother at the time who was still a
teenager I experienced how it felt for
some like they were living in a police
state but yet I also witnessed how
Brixton refused to be marginalized and
criminalized as it rose up during the
riots of the 1980s and rejected this
definition of the existence it should
have by society's standards now you know
defining yourself outside of the realms
of society it's not easy and as a writer
and director it's it's such an
interesting and fascinating subject to
me that it's risen to the fore of every
single project I've ever worked on and
probably every single project I'll ever
do and I think what the reason is
because it's so it's so complex and I
think what's so hard about it is to
recognize when your choices in your
direction in life are being influenced
by societies perhaps more restricted
ideas of who you should be
you know when the mirror image of what
society is suggesting to you doesn't
reflect the person that you really feel
you are or even worse when the untrue
image that's coming back to you
does feel real because the messages and
the influence can be so subtle that it's
just easy to dismiss you know this is
just the way things are supposed to be
that's what you tell yourself and you
think about how many use that argument
when it came to the transatlantic slave
trade or against the women who demanded
the vote or even today
when it comes to gay marriage and think
how many institutions I can think of
them right now
organizations use outdated you know
antiquated biased rules to maintain the
status quo and sometimes an unjust
status quo you know we've been doing
this for X amount of years X and X
amount of years and so we can't change
it now
it's just it's tradition so where they
like to use tradition and you know for
me I think that it sounds unevolved to
not move forward because you think
something is tradition and yet when
society is acting to prevent you from
reaching your goals in your dreams I
think that's precisely the time you have
to truly remember who you are and the
reason why I believe that is because
today
none of us emerge from just one that
single world we're all a combination of
many worlds put together and sometimes
when you are at the junction of many
worlds society considers you a
contradiction you know growing up as I
say down the road from here I
experienced the common story of
constantly being asked where are you
from where are you from and I'd say well
actually I was born here in London and
then I'd be her and no but where are you
really from you know like what part of
London don't you get and then
interestingly I would go back to Ghana
and to visit my grandma grandmother's
with my mother during summer vacation
and I would be told well you're not
really Ghanian are you because you're
too English and it got to the point
where at this Junction that I was
sitting out I didn't know which path
pathway to go down because if I took one
pathway it would be rejected if I took
another pathway that would be rejected
and it felt like in many ways Society
was defining me as an outsider and as I
say again and I'll keep saying it you
know this doesn't have to be solely
about race or gender we're all at the
junction of many worlds it can be a
concerning rays that can be concerning
class sexuality so many different things
today and I don't think our what I'm
wondering at least if there's a person
in this room who at least at some point
in their life hasn't been identified
outside of the realms of that which they
have felt that they would see themselves
or at some point at least hasn't felt
like an outsider and for me I don't
think it should be about having to pick
one pathway over another
I shouldn't have to pick being you know
British over being Guardian or being
garni and over being British because
ultimately I'm a product of both who
both of those cultures reside inside me
and you know it shouldn't really matter
if that's not normal to society for me
it's not so much about a collision of
world as it is a combining of worlds and
as I say it shouldn't matter it really
shouldn't matter whether Society defines
it as normal or not because as the late
dr. Maya Angelou would say if we're
always trying so hard to be normal
how can we ever know how amazing we can
be now you know bringing to bear your
definition of yourself in society as I
say I know it can be hard um there are
all sorts of things our beauty ideals
gender expectations for both men and
women you know racial profiling class
prejudice these are all examples of how
we can be thrown off base in terms of um
knowing and understanding and defining
who we know we truly are um you know I'm
thinking now about um you know the the
guy who wants to stand in his truth when
it comes to his sexuality even though
his community or his religion might
expect something different of him those
who find that you know they define
selves as beautiful but society is
telling them that they're not and I
think to myself that at those points
exactly when society is telling you
you're not who you feel you are that's
the time as I say that you have to
understand the power of what it means to
define yourself how it can mean the
difference between whether you may be
happy or less happy in life a failure or
a success in life but most importantly
conscious or unconscious in the story of
your own life I think back now to at
finding my way originally in the
business of film and being told so often
you know you know it's very hard to sell
black movies with a black protagonist
and you know there are enough movies
today that have defied that definition
and shown that to be untrue but
regardless of whether that was just
opinion or whether that was perception
or whether it was truth or not I
realized that if I was going to move
forward in the business I was going to
have to try and find a way of working
out what the obstacles were and finding
a way to negotiate those obstacles and
what I learned is that when you truly
embrace who you are and all of the
worlds that you come from when you bring
those sensibilities to a previously
closed off world you move society
forward because when we move into other
worlds we touch people we impact people
and when people change then society has
to do as well and for me the value of
embracing all of the worlds exists that
existing you and get this is that those
of us who are able to do that have an
insight that show us why colliding
worlds on the outside
not a bad thing because when worlds meet
progress can follow you know the mother
who may run the fortune 500 company the
son of a cleaner who becomes a doctor or
think about the children the first
african-american children to set foot in
the all-white schools after segregation
was abolished those are all and people
that inspire me to do what I do and I'm
thinking now about the women who do make
their way in the male-dominated world of
filmmaking and what we realize about
those women is that when they're able to
break into that world they make an
impact the British Film Institute
released figures between 2010 and 2012
that show that although women were still
underrepresented when it came to
independent filmmaking they represented
a significant figure or percentage when
it came to successful films people loved
their films and that's what I mean when
I say when we when we have the courage
to move forward into other worlds we
have the impact to change them and it
takes me back to the story that I
started with stepping onto the set of my
first film and a few weeks before I was
about to shoot that movie a film
executive came up to me and said well
you're not going to step on set with
your big high heels on are you as if to
say you know me coming on set with high
heels was really going to be the thing
that established me as a woman in a
man's world and for the record I don't
direct in high heels and I didn't direct
my first film in high heels except from
the last day I always make that a
tradition but I did celebrate my love
for heels in this way I don't know how
clear that is for everybody but it's
essentially a high heel and on the name
of my company and that appeared at the
end of the movie and was the logo for
company you see I believe in leaning in
to our identity not leaning back and
high heels are definitely a part of my
identity but you see I believe that the
part of me that loves high heels and
loves being a woman is every bit the
part of me that is able to write movies
direct movies and deliver movies just as
in the way that the part of me where
Africa meets Europe is the thing that
gives me my unique yet universal eye you
see I believe every industry every
business every society requires fresh
eyes you know to open new windows on old
concepts and unseen worlds to bring new
perspectives to the universal experience
now the journey for me of defining
myself is is an ongoing experience I am
working it every day but if you ask me
the question today who are you and where
are you from I can tell you this I'm a
black British woman I am proudly born of
Ghanaian parents and I'm a screenwriter
and a movie director now how will you
define you thank you
you